E
AP FORFUNDS, 75F THE
MONEY MIGHT ANYFIALL.
CHRIS KREBS IS THE FR
DIRECTOR OF CYBER S
INFRASTRUCTUREECY
AT  KNOWN
T PRONOUNCE
NTAFTEOR
AND OUS THOSE INTEGTYEECTION.
T START TAI CAMPAIGN AND
OTHERS OUTTHERE, M
UINK,D T
THESES, THESE LIES,
DO  JUST GRIF'M NOTE CIGATEGY I
THINKT AMERICANS AS STATES
ACROSSTA CERTIFYING
VOT BASIS THAT SOVTHE  A MOVEFN
TOORE
TRUMPTT LINWOOD ANDEL
MODERANGED CONIRINAUSE T
SPECTRUM OF THEM, THEY ONE
OFHE STEAL RALLIES
THIS RLI AND CTUALLY DISCOUR
GEA FROM VOTING
AT ALL IN THE R JANUARY
TAKE
>> I THINK I WOULD ERAGE ALLAKE
VOTE IS SECURE THEY HAVE NAR
VOTE!
DON'T YOVE IT TOM! V
INNOTHER RIGGED
SAKE!
>> A FACTUALMAOT SECURE AND
REDEE I NOTGG WHAT THEY ARE SAYO
TR
S YOURGE TOS OUT THE
POLITICAL STRIFE?
>> THE IS VOTE.
GENDVOTE.
JANUARY 5th WERE EAONF
FF, VOTE.
IF YOU HAVE OR
E VOTING
INHEN YOU
THATT THAT ITSETE YOU PICKED.
IF YOU'RE VOTING MAKE MING THA
CANRLOLI
THERE ARE SECURITT IN TOHEROCES
DURING,CURITY OF TH CLAIMS OF A
ACCOMPLISH.
HOW MUCH DOES THATHAVE L THERE
VEEFFECT?HE NEV T
THE END LLME LOOKHEIR TRUSTED
SO OF INFORMATION INTIHE
STATOCAL
OFFICIALS.
THE SECRETA
WE STILL SAY IF'R I
GE GO LISTERETARYFFENSPERR. EE M
ON
INK IT'S EFFEPOS FOR
DISINFORMATION GOI FWA THETHE O
SO INFORMATION OUT MAKE DECISIO
>> AS
PRESIDENTMP ANDLL
ACCOUNTS, DEMOCND
WAS
WE WELL
REGARDED, IF HAD FIVE
MITEREDE TO
HI IIME KIN ADOEDUR
NOLLA BUTENDERE MORE IMPNUR-YEA
UNNC ARE VERY D, DON'T
KNOW WS NEXT.
BUOT MAKE
CONTINUE PROVI T>> IT'S SAY
THAT IT'SECAUSE I'VE
NOTICED THIEBATE OUT
THERE SAY, DAY, WHAT TID AND NO
ECTIONS. SIDE WITH THE OTHER
TO GIVE MON ONTHIC T SYSTEM BUT
ONLY BECAUSE
AND NOTFAD BEEN A
THOU ONETAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENEN
REPUBLICAN, OR THE  IPHILADPH
SCHMIDT IS REPUBLICAN, O
RAFFENSPER SRY OF  W
REPUBLICAN.
B
RALICANS WTIN F PEOPLE ARESA
YOU ARE  T
WHO
>>SURE.
A GOODON. QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, ONHE 2020 ECT ME ONE
IMPOANNTS BETWEEN
16 AAS OF
BOTH PENNSYLVANIA AND D ARA CP
TO GETHATPA
YET.
WE G P  M THE W THINK  WECOFORW
DEMOCR HEO GIVE MORE STEAD
REESTMENT TOLEOFFICIALS IS ONE.E
RNATHER IS WE IN CIVINSPACE.
WE HAVE KIS.
>> THIS WEEK TORING UP
SOTHE AND'M
VE THERE AS A PUBLIC  I GENEVAAI
TAKENNDNG TO SA BEING
SARCASTIC. H SARCASTICORNG THAT
YO.
I TWHINK IT'S TON TALKED ABOFF
S THAT ANG DE  SMEDIA,NE,MESSAG
THESE AREESE ARE THE HEROES
THAT AREDEMOCRACY, THEY ARE EAT.
THHAECRUITING ELECTION S GF  WOF
LAWYERSND
TAGE OFURON'S
LAWS WHEN ITES TO TH T
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
LOOKINGLUIO UWH S OR
AND WE WILL TALKOURT ANDITAT AR
>> A RAYS THAT 3 OUT
OF TRU VOTERS
ERRONEOUSL ANGLY BEL
THAT JOE BIDEN ONLYECAUSE OF VO.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN,
REPUBLICAN OF OENTRUMP'S ARDENT
SUORG,
TAKEOO MMA
I KNOW TTNECESS INVESGAELECTIO
ATER THIS WEEK HE
FRAUD AT THE
SCALE THAT WOULD FLIP THE
OUTCOME OF THISTE.
AGAIN, L SOURCES.LI T O PRETTY
C FACEDH
COVID, THE EXPANSION OFOTS, IT O
HEADED A SECTI Y TOE
THE ELECTION WAS AS AST
E
YE T ISLW AN ERE OYOU ?
YOU HAVE MILLIONS OF PEOPL
VO IS GOING T
NERYCLEAN, EFFICIENT
ELECTION. HEAR JUST TINUT SOME
SOFTWARE THATPSCOMMUN  WHATTH
WHEN IT COMES FROM NOT JUST  ORA
HO LIKE? LOOK.
IF YOU'RE GOING  M
CLAIMS OF ROVE
IT. YET TO